eu dos 16 17 anos pra frente eu já
morava sozinho e o bonde você morava
sozinha é que você mora sozinho né ali
sozinho agora O ruim é que você mora só
sozinho não é sozinho só normal é só com
força mesmo né tipo assim você tá
sozinha ali na sala e sua mãe tá no
banheiro é você tá ali na sala e a loira
do banheiro tá no banheiro e o filme de
terror ele Começa umas 11:00 da noite
mas termina depois da meia-noite e eu
tenho uma superstição que é o seguinte
para mim depois da meia-noite o Satanás
ele começa a andar por dentro da sua
casa e o filme é baseado em fatos reais
eu trago a realidade do filme pra minha
vida se no filme tiver uma muriçoca
muriçoca sempre meu amigo meu Deus do
céu essa menina só que vai me matar cara
eu nunca te fiz nada eu fico pensando
que é que tem a ver medo de ter um monte
debaixo da cama O que que tem a ver
ficar embaixo da cama assombração só
escolhe lugar esquisito né um quer ficar
embaixo da cama a loira do banheiro quer
ir para o banheiro que diabo que a loira
do banheiro quer ficar no banheiro podia
ser uma loira loira da sala a loira do
quarto ou podia ser pelo menos banheira
em inglês né A Loira do Bad ROM ela
podia ser loiro da cozinha que minha mãe
certeza quebrava a pau essa loira da
cozinha só que Bora buscar essa tua
amiga estra